hello this is the talk about the
possibility of getting a quantum speed
up for gradient descent
although the title gives away the
conclusion this work was done in
collaboration with my colleagues ankit
gerk robin kothari and pranit netarpalli
well i suhil sharif was an intern at
microsoft research
so gradient descent was introduced in
the mid 19th century by kochi
and it's a simple idea for trying to
minimize
a function that you have only local
access to you
start off with computing the function at
a point then you compute the gradient at
that point
the gradient is a vector which shows you
the direction of steepest ascent
along with the magnitude of that
steepness then you take a step in the
opposite direction with the hope that
you're actually decreasing the function
value
and then you continuously do this step
and at least in this case the function
value seems to be decreasing
it's a simple algorithm and it's
actually used in practice a lot as well
and this is because of the cheap
gradient principle which says that if
you can compute a function in a
structured way
then with a small overhead you can
compute its gradient as well
so for example in neural networks where
there are lots of parameters and we want
to find parameters
in which the loss function is minimized
you would use gradient descent
when you try to abstract out the process
of gradient descent
where you just have access to function
value oracle you also need access to a
function gradient oracle
because at least for high dimensional
functions computing the gradient
is not easy if you can compute the
function value in a black box setting
the question we want to ask is is there
a quantum advantage to be had
and it turns out that it's not a
ridiculous question for instance
using quantum algorithms you can
actually find the gradient with one
query to the function value oracle
regardless of the dimension so one could
hope that perhaps
with less than k queries we can get the
result of k gradient descent steps
if this were possible this would put it
among
many other useful subroutines that
actually do have quantum speedups
but if it's not possible is that an
interesting result saying that
you have to use k queries to get the
result of k gradient descent steps
it sounds like a stringent requirement
so we'd want a
formulation in which a negative result
would actually be interesting
so we want a task that gradient descent
solves that quantum cannot solve any
faster
so the question is what is it that
gradient descent really accomplishes
without getting into the details like
the gradient descent steps
and a pretty good fit for this is convex
optimization
so in convex optimization you're given a
convex region which we'll assume is a
ball
for the purposes of this talk and you're
given oracle access by which i mean
function value and gradients
to a convex function f and we want to
know
what is the point at which f takes its
minimum value
this is impossible to solve it could
take arbitrarily many queries
so instead you relax it and you ask to
find a point
in this convex region which need not be
the optimal but where the function value
is at most epsilon more than the optimal
value
for instance these functions here where
we want to just find one of these red
points
now it turns out this isn't enough to
specify the problem as well even under
this specification you could take
arbitrarily many queries
so another thing that you need to know
is how steep your function is
for example the function on the right
here is just a scaled version of the
function on the left
scaled by a factor of three but you can
see as a consequence of this
the epsilon optimal points is a much
smaller region
than it is on the left of course you
could scale it back
to make it look like the unskilled
version but even then
the fraction of points that we are
interested in is a much smaller region
and this is uh so for example here since
we've scaled by a factor of three
on the right side here we're looking at
the unskilled function but we're trying
to
optimize it to a precision of epsilon by
3.
and this is a general thing so we can
just assume that
the functions we're trying to optimize
have slope at most one
and we're trying to optimize them in a
ball or radius one and the other
the actual values of the slope and
radius we can just push into the epsilon
parameter
so we're just going to assume that all
our functions now are one lip shades in
a ball of radius one
now convexity guarantees us that if you
take the gradient at any point that is
if you take the hyperplane
that is tangent to that point it stays
below the function at all points
however convexity doesn't guarantee that
such a tangent exists
so for example you take the smooth
function there are points
where there is no tangent
so here we have multiple
planes that do pass through this point
and they do stay completely below
the curve so any of these points is a
valid
sub gradient and instead of having a
gradient oracle access
we're going to have access to a
subgradient article
so that specifies our convex
optimization task
the question is what algorithms do we
know for convex optimization
now in the one-dimensional case we can
actually perform a binary search
you find the value at one point you find
out in which direction
the function decreases and you
just half your space to just
within this region
now we can continue this and find
smaller and smaller values
the question is how many uh steps do we
need of binary search before we find an
epsilon optimal point
since our function has slope at most
epsilon at at most one
the set of epsilon optimal points is
going to be at least an epsilon ball
around the minimum and we're going to
land within this epsilon ball
within log one by epsilon steps and this
is the best you can do
for an n-dimensional function can we
still do binary search
turns out we can there's the center of
gravity method
which essentially cuts down on the
volume in which you're searching by a
constant factor at every query
but the number of queries it needs to
actually reach an optimal point
is actually large the epsilon optimal
points can just be an
epsilon ball around the minimum which
has a volume 1 by epsilon to the n
so the number of steps is here n log 1
by epsilon it depends on the dimension
on the other hand gradient descent
doesn't care about the dimension of your
input space
it just walks along the direction
opposite to the gradient
it's it's a one-dimensional walk so to
speak
and this reflects is it is reflected in
its complexity
so project it's a gradient descent where
you're getting access
to subgradients instead of gradients and
every time you step
outside the convex region you project
yourself back within the convex region
this algorithm does find an epsilon
optimal point within one by epsilon
square steps
so the conclusion here is that gradient
descent actually beats binary search
when the dimension is large and that's
quite impressive
so if you want to know whether convex
whether gradient descent can be speeded
up by quantum algorithms
we need just look over here so if
there is a speed up then there should be
a dimension
independent quantum upper bound that is
better than one by epsilon square
what do we know about the optimality of
gradient descent we know that it's the
optimal deterministic algorithm
in large dimensions this was known for
like what four decades now i guess so
it's also the optimal randomized
algorithm although
the work here is a bit less than done in
the deterministic case and we know this
only when the dimension is large
so in our paper we actually reprove this
result and show that when
the dimension is as small as 1 by
epsilon square it still is the optimal
randomized algorithm
for the quantum setting there have been
some recent works in convex optimization
but they have been in slightly different
regimes so
for instance it was known that
the dimension through a dimension
dependent work
by chakraborty child's lian wu
it's a corollary of one of their
theorems that quantum algorithms also
require at least one by epsilon queries
for dimension independent
uh convex optimization and we prove that
in fact it requires one by epsilon
square queries so there is no
speed up at all not even a constant in
fact
over gradient descent
so this is the introduction to what our
work does
and now we'll move on to some technical
details let's see how the lower bounds
look
both our lower bonds follow a similar
theme so that's easier for me to explain
we want to find functions that encode
some kind of information
in the sense that if you find an epsilon
optimal point for f
you've actually learned the encoded
information
then you want to say that every query
accesses this information in a very
controlled manner
and this gives us a handle to say that
you actually need
a lot of queries in order to learn all
of the information
so let's start with the randomized lower
bond this function class
that we use has been used again for many
decades
but we're going to show that we're going
to show a pretty strong lower bond for
it
so it starts with a base function which
takes an n dimensional input
and it outputs the maximum of the
coordinates
the minimum value that this function
takes in the unit ball
is negative 1 over square root n and it
takes this value at the point where all
the coordinates are negative 1 over
square root n
if you query the subgradient oracle of f
what it returns
is just the direction of the maximum
coordinate so if the maximum coordinate
is x
i then e i is actually a sub gradient
now this is just one function so if
you're trying to minimize it you don't
need to query anything
you can just point out that oh the
minimum happens over here
so we're going to need a function class
over here and
we do that we create a function class of
2 to the n many functions
where the difference between the
functions is that some of the bits
some of the coordinates are flipped so
it's the same as the base function
except that some of the coordinates are
flipped and which coordinates are
flipped are specified by this
string z the minimum is still the same
and it's taken at the same point but
with the coordinates flipped
appropriately and we said epsilon to be
0.9 by square root n so a consequence of
this is that if you have an epsilon
optimal point
its function value is negative
so this function class encodes the
string z
in the sense that if you find an epsilon
optimal point
you've also learned set because
if x i ever has the same sign as zi
then the function value is positive and
so it's not epsilon optimal
so if you have an epsilon optimal point
you can look at the signs of x
i and just read off the string z from it
how about what the query gives us access
to
well when we make a query x what we do
is we're sorting the coordinates of x by
absolute value
in descending order we're finding the
first coordinate
where x i has the same sign as zi and if
z is a uniformly random string
we should expect this to happen pretty
soon because each coordinate has a half
chance of having the same
sign and the output that we get from the
oracles are the absolute value of x i
and the great sub gradient e i which
reveals no information
about the later coordinates of z
so if we take z uniformly at random
we're learning around
two bits per query and so we need omega
n queries
in order to find an epsilon optimal
point and that's an omega 1 by epsilon
squared lower bond
however if we look at the quantum
algorithms we do have a quantum
algorithm that
can speed up this process at least
quadratically
and the way to see this is that we can
implement an
or query on z with a single query to f
and we can then use bellows algorithm to
learn z
using square root and many ore queries
so what function class do we need for a
quantum lower bond
in a recent paper a couple of years ago
bubek
young lee lee and sitford
showed a lower bond on the highly
parallel convex
optimization problem where
you're allowed to make non-adaptive
queries in a round and you're asking how
many rounds do we need
and the techniques that they use are
they seemed quite useful
in order to prove a quantum lower bond
and they did prove useful
so our function class is almost the same
as their function class
and this has been used in previous works
in past decades but
the techniques that were used now are
pretty helpful for quantum
so the function is similar to our
previous function except in two major
ways
one is that although the input is still
an n-dimensional vector
the maximum the the term where we're
taking the maximum here
only has k terms in it so even though
it's an
dimensional vector we're just taking the
maximum of k components of it
the second difference is that we're
subtracting a small constant gamma
and as we go through the maximum this
the number of times we're subtracting it
increases this since gamma is small
doesn't change the global properties of
f so f's minimum is still approximately
minus 1 by square root k
and it takes it at a point very similar
to the points we've seen earlier
so what's the function class that we get
from the base function
for this we look at k orthonormal
vectors in an n-dimensional space
and we think of n as being really large
and we use these vectors in order to
uh replace x1 through xk so instead of
x1 we have v1 inner product x
and so on till vk inner product x apart
from that is the same function
and another way to look at this function
is that we're rotating
our input uniformly at random in n
dimensions
before then applying the same function
on it so it will have the same global
properties
its minimum will still be at minus 1 by
square root k and
the point will be the same point
appropriately rotated
we set epsilon again to be 0.9 by square
root k
and this ensures that the function value
at the
for any epsilon optimal point is still
going to be at least minus
well at most minus 0.1 by square root k
this function class encodes the set v
although
in a certain sense and that sense is
that
if you find an epsilon optimal point x
what you've actually done is you found
an x which has
a non-trivial component along each of
the v i's
so we need so if your point x is epsilon
optimal
at least and each of these points
how do i put this
so if your point x is an epsilon optimal
point
then none of these vi inner product x
terms
can be much larger than minus 0.1 by
square root k
they should all be smaller than minus
1.1 by square root k
and if you just take a random x v i
inner product x
is going to be around order 1 by square
root n and since n is really large
this is a trivial correlation and we
need a much larger correlation
with vi in order to find in order to be
epsilon optimal
and the query access to rvis is
that vi is nearly unknown before the ith
query if you've made i minus one queries
you practically don't know vi so these
two points in
conjunction with each other would mean
that you need k queries because if
you've only made k
minus one queries vk is unknown and if
vk is unknown
then you only have one by square root n
correlation with v k whereas you need it
to be much larger
so what do you mean by v i is nearly
unknown before the i query
suppose you know v1 and v2 and you know
nothing else about v
through v 3 through v k so they're still
uniformly at random
from an n minus 2 dimensional space
if you take any x in the unit ball with
high probability
v i inner product x is going to be
around
order 1 by square root n because v i is
uniformly at random from a high
dimensional ball
and with exponentially small probability
it's going to be as large as log n by
square root n
and we can keep n large enough so that
this is smaller than gamma
so with high probability each of our v3
inner product x v4 inner product x and
so on
are much smaller than gamma and so if we
look at these terms
starting from the third term v3 inner
product x minus 2 gamma is approximately
minus 2 gamma
v4 inner product x minus 3 gamma is
approximately -3 gamma so this is
the order of the later terms apart from
v1 and v2
so how does this give us a quantum lower
bond
we go through the hybrid argument to
reach there and
it's a pretty neat argument so suppose
you have a k
minus one query algorithm that you claim
is doing well
on this task your first query you're
going to create
a superposition of inputs so here the
inputs are x i you
you've created a superposition of x i
and you're going to pass it to the
function value oracle
now before you pass it to the function
value oracle
i'm going to change the oracle to a
different oracle which only has
information about the first term of the
maximum
so in this case it's just v one inner
product x
and you have a right to be annoyed that
i've switched out your oracle
but you can't really claim that
your algorithm is spoiled because i
switched out the oracle
this is an inconsequential change since
we don't know what v1 is
we don't know v1 through vk it's highly
probable
that in fact with high probability v1
inner product x is going to be the
maximum term
so for most of the inputs in the
superposition
they're not going to notice a difference
whether i use the original oracle or
this
modified oracle and so
the output states after going through
this modified oracle is going to be very
close to the output state if it had gone
through the original oracle
and since quantum algorithms or any
quantum process
is is made out of unitary rotations
the fact that the output states are
close after the first oracle call
is going to imply that the output states
are the same at the end so if
if you run this algorithm through to the
end the final quantum states that you
have
are still going to be close because you
always had dimension
distance preserving transformations in
the middle
and what this means is that your output
itself is going to be close
in total variational distance
so all right you've accepted that this
is an inconsequential change
and you've decided to you know put it in
the past and go to the second query
now the second query you've done some
operations
again you're going to pass it through
oracle and again
i replace it with this limited
information article where it's only
limited to the first two terms
of the maximum now since the first
oracle that it went through didn't have
any information about v2
and so on before you pass through the
second query
v2 through vk are still completely
unknown and again what that means
is that the second term is going to be
larger with high probability than any of
the later terms
so again this is an inconsequential
change and again you can argue that
if your algorithm was correct the
original algorithm then these changes
are hardly making any difference it
should still be correct
and we can do this for k minus one
queries after k minus 1 queries
the argument still holds that the
outputs of the original and the modified
algorithms
should be pretty much the same
but notice that the k minus 1 times
changed algorithm the algorithm where
i've switched out the oracle k minus one
times
it's completely independent of vk all
the oracles were completely independent
of vk
and what this means is that this
algorithm cannot
cannot output an epsilon optimal point
because
its correlation with v k is going to be
trivial
so what this means is that the original
algorithm also is not going to have an
epsilon optimal output
and that concludes the lower bond you do
need k
queries in order to find out what v k is
and
output an epsilon optimal point
it turns out that projected sub gradient
descent
does also accomplish this task in k
queries
and if you look through the details it
doesn't actually use any projections
and it queries only smooth points so
it's basically
gradient descent itself that has done it
in k queries
and this is a pretty convincing way to
say that
there is no quantum speedup over
gradient deception
the actual function that we use is
actually slightly modified because we
might query outside the unit ball as
well and we want to account for those
it's a small modification and i'm not
going to go into it here
other points of note is that the n
actually doesn't have to be really large
it can be as small as 1 by epsilon to
the 6.
and with the modification that's
actually taken from the same bubecker
all paper
you can bring n down to 1 by epsilon to
the 4.
so what does this leave as open
questions
well the main one is what is the quantum
complexity of convex optimization in
small dimensions
it's still open that for n smaller than
1 by epsilon to the 4
there is a quadratic speed up
what other classes of convex
optimization problems would get quantum
speedups
we know that there are convicts
optimization tasks like semi-definite
optimization that do get quantum speed
ups and we know that
our first randomized lower bound did
also get a quantum speed up
but we don't really have an idea of when
exactly you do get quantum speedups and
when you don't so some clarity on that
would be nice
and in particular this very function
class here where
we don't put the gammas but we do put
the vectors v1 through vk
for this function class what is the
quantum complexity
we know a lower bound of order square
root k omega square root k and we have
an upper bound a simple upper bound of
order k
but we don't know where exactly it lies
that is my talk thank you for listening
goodbye